just fed up to 46 knots
50 knots closing in
ufos are real america every day it feels
like we get another video of an
identified flying object zipping across
the sky so why does it
seem like the u.s military is more
concerned with pushing the woke agenda
than the very real threat
of aliens maybe the aliens have read
white fragility
my next guest was recently fired as a
space force commander for decrying
marxism in the military
in his new book in resistive revolution
lieutenant colonel matthew lowe meyer
claims marx's ideologies are becoming
too prevalent
in the u.s military he has brought his
case to congress meeting with several
senators
about the issue this week lieutenant
lowe meyer joins
me now lieutenant colonel thank you so
much for joining me
uh what is your big beef with the
military of today can you explain the
type of marxism
that is being taught uh in the military
lawrence thanks for having me my big
beef that's the first time it's been put
that way i like that question
i'll say first i don't speak for the
defense department these are my own
personal views
although it's clear to me that i'm not
alone in these views
the country has become increasingly
aware of something
at least in the past several weeks if
not over the last year and it's critical
race theory
critical race theory is the grandchild
of critical theory which was created by
marxists who came over here about a
century ago
from germany and the frankfurt school
and that's
the marxism that i'm specifically
identifying in my book
and that i've been talking about on a
number of shows recently and
fortunately as i pointed out it's not
just me there's a group
that i came to know about in the last
several months called stars
s-t-a-r-r-s stand together against
racism and radicalism in the services
and whereas just a couple weeks ago that
group had several dozen
retired alumni from across all of the
service academies that's
membership in the last couple of weeks
has boomed over 600
1600 members of very concerned
uh retired general officers and other
retired officers and service members
uh and and other concerned citizens so
it's not just me that's concerned about
it
it's it's me it's them it's other
parents in our school system
and this is something that's uh not just
in the us military but seems to be
across our entire society so you met
with the senators today
um did you get any feedback is there
going to be some type of
investigation there
yeah so i was really grateful there have
been uh a great deal of congressmen and
senators who have shown
interest in these issues and support uh
for me and and for the
the ideas that i was hoping to share
with them as well and so at their
request i was out in washington dc the
past several days
in my private capacity but to talk about
my experiences in the military
senator tom cotton from arkansas spent a
lot of time with me
and my attorney senator ted cruz also
met with me and congressman mike waltz
former green beret
and a number of hask and hecti staffers
whose congressmen and congresswoman
women recently wrote a letter in my
support
requesting my reinstatement a great deal
of congressman congresswoman have shown
support for this and great concern over
what
it is that they've been hearing from me
but not just from me but from others now
across the services they've lent a
tremendous amount of support
they're looking into this they're
gathering documents at the moment
trying to understand exactly what the
problem is
and i think that the the picture is
becoming clearer and clearer to them and
and i
i won't pretend to know what it is
they'll do with that information but i
know that they're very concerned
yeah we're going to keep following that
but now the real question is the
lieutenant colonel
now you're part of space force
where are these ufos do they exist are
they real
what can you tell us because that's what
we really want to know
hey that's a that's a fun question i was
on tucker uh several days ago
he asked me the same question he was
hoping for a really juicy space for
story
that i might have for him and i told him
look if i knew something
related to my job about that i probably
wouldn't tell you but i had
my own experience in high school in the
in the mountains of tucson and in fact
saw something
that i can only describe as a ufo and i
wasn't alone there was someone else with
me
late at night when we saw it and it was
a very unique experience
i can't describe it you can go listen to
what i said on tucker about it
but uh clearly they're they're real
whatever they are uh whether
you know and there's a lot of people
speculating about that what that is and
i won't
uh but yeah that's something worth
looking into so
should we be concerned as americans i
mean i don't want you to violate your
position but
hell i think this may unify us if we
realize that the aliens they're gonna
come for all of us they don't care what
shade of color we are
well there are many issues that we have
an opportunity to unify around
one of the things in fact going back to
the topic we initially brought up which
is critical race theory
it's my contention that marxist ideology
is not
a partisan political uh issue
because it's antithetical to america's
founding values and philosophy this is
something that provides us an
opportunity
uh to unite and show a kind of you know
if we're talking politics bipartisan
support for america's founding values
in the face of the onslaught of marxist
ideology and in fact
i pointed out in my book and elsewhere
uh we fought the cold war
uh over the spread and to contain the
spread of marxist communist ideology in
the world and and we spent a great deal
of treasures and blood and iron
in the past half century doing that and
so i'd hate to think
uh and in fact other service members who
have written me uh letters
would hate to think that some of their
loved ones in fact uh
went to war over these very issues and
now we're not allowed to speak up about
it when we see it
yeah it's a dangerous thing and they
want to suppress speech as well
lieutenant colonel thank you so much for
joining the program hey happy to be here
with you thanks lawrence